bonjour à toutes et à tous les invités
de ça au caddie ce matin john montrose
présidente du comité de soutien à
françois fillon mongeau bonjour à
monsieur livre i et bonjour aux aux
auditrices et aux auditeurs de martini
première et permettez-moi ans celui mars
d'avoir une pensée particulière pour les
femmes martiniquaise encore une
révélation du canard enchaîné ce matin
l'île de madère affirme que françois
fillon a obtenu un prêt de 50 mille
euros non déclarée à la haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
auprès de son ami milliardaire marc
ladreit de lacharrière celui qui a
embauché feu pénélope fillon
un prêt qui a été remboursé quand même
mais écoutez je ne doute pas que des
révélations nous en ouvrons et nous en
ouvrons et nous donnerons encore je veux
simple simplement dire qu'il n'ya pas du
tribunal médiatique nous l'avons bien vu
nous avons des révélations qui ont fait
l'objet pour françois fillon d'une
saisine d'une auto saisine du parquet
national financiers et je constate qu'à
l'issue de l'enquêté du parquet national
financier il n'y avait pas suffisamment
d'éléments pour traduire directement
notre candidat en correctionnelle
puisque c'était une des options du
parquet national financiers donc je dis
que la justice aujourd'hui fasse son
travail et qu'on rentre définitivement
dans cette campagne
alors justement françois client a gagné
son bras de fer plus de plan b possible
vous êtes soulagé écoutez nous étions
déjà convaincu et nous étions sereins et
confiants
françois fillon personne ne peut
aujourd'hui contester la légitimité de
françois fillon
je veux simplement signalé qu'il a été
élu à l'issue d'une primaire au françois
fillon à lui seul a fait plus de deux
voix réunit que nos sept candidats de la
gauche aux primaires puisqu'il a été élu
par plus de 3 millions de français donc
je crois que personne ne peut
aujourd'hui contester la légitimité de
françois fillon
maintenant la famille républicaine et
rassembler autour de notre candidat on
verra pendant cette émission hier lors
de son meeting à orly
il a invoqué jeanne d'arc et qu'ils ont
tant les membres des républicains les
élus les militants à passer outre
donc il faut passer outre ce tout ce qui
lui est reproché il faut passer outre le
l'orgue est il faut passer outre sa
possible mise en examen
non il faut pas passer autre tout il
faut simplement être consciente de la
situation dans laquelle la france est
aujourd'hui nous avons une une france
qui nous a été laissé par monsieur
hollande dans une situation
catastrophique
qu'est ce que nous avons en face de nous
quelqu'un qui considère que faire des
promesses électorales à promettre aux
foyers y compris martiniquaise et
martiniquais de supprimer 80 % pour 80%
des foyers la taxe d'habitation et bien
c'est une solution
eh bien je veux dire si ça c'est une
solution c'est ne pas connaître le
fonctionnement des collectivités et je
veux bien croire que ce candidat ne
connaît pas puisqu'il n'a jamais été
lui-même élu donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut être conscient de
la situation dans laquelle la france est
la martinique est on ne peut pas
considérer que nous avons une offre
aujourd'hui françois fillon un programme
qui vise deux objectifs la liberté le
plein emploi et c'est ce que nous devons
défendre son manque de dignité de
françois fillon dans une société
française on l'y assimile aux chômeurs
50000 en martinique une société qui
produit de plus en plus de travailleurs
pauvres des travailleurs précaires
il y a et dieu merci une lucidité de nos
candidats j'ai toujours dit lorsque je
suis venu sur vos antennes que je
soutenais françois fillon pour trois
raisons l'homme la méthode est le
programme
je crois que ces quelques ares et on a
tendance à oublier qu'il n'est pas parti
en campagne aujourd'hui comme certains
ça fait trois ans que françois fillon
fut sillonnent le terrain et si
aujourd'hui on devait donner un objectif
au programme de françois fillon il le
dit lui même c'est le programme du plein
emploi et c'est parce qu'il à cet
objectif
qu'aujourd'hui le françois fillon au but
au sol eh bien il est totalement il est
totalement connectée et permettez-moi de
vous dit
demandez aux autres candidats quand
aujourd'hui il favorise plus
l'assistanat que le mérite et que le
travail est ce que c'est la demande des
étudiantes et des étudiants martiniquais
françois fillon aujourd'hui totalement
connectée parce qu'il est justement
conscients que nous avons de plus en
plus de pauvres de plus en plus de
chômeurs est l'axé principal de son
travail et de libérer les énergies et de
favoriser le plein emploi comment est
bien effectivement en proposant aux
entreprises une baisse de 40 milliards
des charges
je vous signale que pour l'autre mère
justement qui est en décalage par
rapport au plan national
françois fillon propose de plus un
programme de 2 milliards d'euros par an
pour favoriser ce plein emploi et c'est
la raison pour laquelle également
françois fillon nous dit comme je
l'avais déjà dit
déjà lors du débat des primaires que la
la la la la mesure qui vise à la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
postes de fonctionnaires n'est pas
valable pour les outre-mer temps que la
machine à engranger des emplois n'est
pas aujourd'hui réamorcer donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui à voter pour un candidat
au sol et l'eau l'homme souscrivit la
toile on est ce que il est audible mais
vie il est connecté à considérer vos
l'homme madame montrose moi je vais vous
dire une chose
encore une fois vous me demandez si
françois fillon est audible
puis je vous dis regardez l'offre que
nous avons qu'elle offre nous n'avons
pas d'autre alternative
quand un candidat aujourd'hui dans les
problématiques que nous connaissons en
particulier en martinique propose comme
solution pour nos jeunes
la dépénalisation du cannabis vous
pensez que l'huile et audible vous
pensez que lui il est connecté vous
pensez que lui n'est pas au seul
lorsqu'aujourd'hui en nous proposant
revenu universel alors qu' il y à un
certain nombre de martiniquais de
martine qu'est-ce qui travaillent et qui
aujourd'hui se lève tous les matins pour
aller travailler
eh bien je crois qu'aujourd'hui ce que
les martiniquaises les martiniquais
demande ce que nos jeunes demandent les
3,4 millions
une qui partent par an c'est de pouvoir
trouver du travail sur leur territoire
et bien je crois que nous avons
aujourd'hui un candidat qui est connecté
et permettez moi de vous dire en cette
journée de la femme
je ne vois pas beaucoup de candidats qui
parle de la situation de la femme je
vois pas beaucoup de candidats qui parle
de la situation du handicap en
martinique
eh bien lorsque nous avons un candidat
qui est bien conscient que les femmes
ont besoin d'être aidés et propose de
développer le télétravail propose
justement à ces femmes a bien qui sont
parfois victimes d'agressions sexuelles
et qui ont des difficultés à porter
plainte parce que le processus de
décision et l'ont alors quand il dit
aujourd'hui qu'il faut allonger le délai
de prescription pour que ces femmes
victimes d'agressions sexuelles puissent
dans ce processus et dans ce cheminement
porter plainte
eh bien je crois qu'au contraire nous
avons un candidat qui répond aux
préoccupations des françaises des
français des martiniquaises et des
martin alors pourquoi georges arnaud
invité hier à sao caddie
jean lanneaux donc porte parole de
l'association culture égalité disait
clairement que le programme de françois
fillon était une régression pour les
droits des femmes notamment dans le
financement du pal des plannings
familiaux et bien je dirais à georges
anneaux simplement s'il y a eu une
régression dans le droit des femmes il
faut que cette régression soit bien
affecté à son auteur
c'est quand même un gouvernement de
gauche c'est quand même un gouvernement
de gauche qui a diminué le quotient des
allocations familiales qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui bon nombre de femmes
isolées martiniquaise bon nombre de ceux
qui sont de la classe moyenne ont vu
pendant ces cinq dernières années
simplement leur allocation supprimer ou
alors diminué pour passer de 200 euros à
27 euros
je ne sais pas si quand on est soucieux
de la femme si quand on est soucieux de
la famille eh bien on a appliqué la
bonne politique
et bien c'est quand même françois fillon
encore une fois connecté qui propose une
réévaluation du quotient familial à
passe pour passer deux à trois mille
euros
eh bien je veux dire or il faut poser
les bons diagnostics pour proposer les
bonnes solutions une dernière question
sur la campagne
on a l'impression que maintenant qu'elle
est inexistante vous attend dès
l'ouverture de la campagne officielle
simplement en à peine 30 secondes en à
peine 30 secondes je vous dirais que dès
ce soir nous sommes dans une réunion de
proximité à saint joseph que vendredi
soir nous sommes dans une réunion à
didier que samedi
l'ensemble de la presse est invitée pour
la présentation de l'équipe de campagne
nous sommes déjà sur le terrain et nous
poursuivons de nombreuses j'ouvre merci
ça aux qualités amylie bonne journée
merci à vous merci
[Musique]